using a 48-inch display as a computer
monitor on a desk or something unheard
of just a few years ago with oled disk
space becoming more affordable even rog
is getting in on the action thus the
pg48uqo led gaming monitor live up to
his tv cousins you have come to the
right place to find out more if you are
thinking of getting an lg zero monitor
or using a massive display on your desk
make sure that you have a surface that's
deep enough
my desk has a depth of 800 millimeters
to allow me to use this in comfort
if you have a monitor arm the pg-48 uq
only supports a 300 by 300 millimeter
v-cell wall mounting
sadly this means i've been unable to use
my egotron desk mount compared to the lg
c1 from before
the legs for this display are actually
pretty wide and measure 29 millimeters
deep and 750 millimeters wide
so you will need to make space to ensure
you're not too near the monitor
otherwise you're in for a neck egg
apart from that this monitor looks great
for most content but you might want to
hold off for an alternative if you can
wait
before we go into more detail here at
geek culture we cover plenty of topics
from tech toys and entertainment so the
next video might be different from this
but we guarantee it to be geeky i've
been checking out plenty of displays and
consumers are support for choice
if you are looking for an oled display
with a displayport look no further than
the rg pg48uq
it seems that rg and alienware are
fighting a proxy battle for lg and
samsung with the aw 3423 dw monitor now
we're back to my room and the light is
pretty much controlled here with no
glare or direct sunlight hitting this
display this is by far one of the best
conditions to use the monitor this oled
display measures 1068 by 686 millimeters
and features small bezels that we have
come to expect with all modern displays
what really stands out is how slim the
unit is as a whole there's no additional
power adapter that sits outwardly
outside of the monitor compared to the
alienware aw3423d
the rog pg-48 uq runs quiet
with displays this size there tends to
be quite a bit of heat generated by the
screen
however i've noticed that the issue is
not as pronounced as the alienware which
came in pretty loud and warm in
comparison rog claims to have placed a
custom heatsink at the back to help
reduce temperatures and is fanless by
design to keep the display quiet
cooler is always better for performance
and to prevent burn in
but we have to see how the display holds
up over time
there's no rgb lights that rg loves to
throw into their products say for a
small logo in the front
even that can be turned off from the
settings menu
with a 98 rating in the dci p3 and 133
in the srgb color space
it's hard to find an oled that doesn't
do its job for anyone getting this
monitor for pc use they can expect the
richest visuals ever
and like they say once you've used an
oled it's hard to go back to anything
else by default the brightest this
display can go up to would be 450 nits
which is not actually that bright
however by going into the menus and
changing the color temp to 10 000
kelvins we are able to hit 872 nits peak
brightness
do note this makes the display look
cooler than the default from the menus
you're able to get a few options that
gives users access to gaming cinema and
console hdr presets but there's little
discernable difference for the different
modes
be sure to test out the various presets
to see what suits your taste and the
content best
overall the colors on this display look
great and if you're looking to use this
professionally
and would like to ensure that your edits
look great across multiple displays i
would imagine that creative folks might
look at this display
if you like a mix of work and play in a
single display the parent company for rg
asus has a good track record when it
comes to displays overall and the pg48
uq does not disappoint
however from our tests it will appear
that the early unit we've received that
struggle has the same changes to display
pure blacks getting up close you are
able to see the oled pattern quite
prominently we found that the issue here
is how windows hdr works together with
the monitor for best results the
preferred option would be to turn
windows hdr off outside of the pc
environment do note that popular
streaming services like disneyplus
and netflix does not seem to recognize
this display
despite it being able to project in 4k
or hdr10
this results in a less than enjoyable
experience overall
sitting close to the display it's hard
to discern if there's any reflectiveness
on screen
rog has implemented an anti-glare micro
texture coating to the screen which i
found to have helped improve the viewing
experience
with most folks who are looking to buy
the rog pg for the uq they'll most
likely sit up close to use the display
outside of gaming applications such as
power toys fancy zones help segment the
screen into grids to help organize
windows i've used this since the days on
my lg c1 and will recommend it to anyone
to use this display optimally with
minimal neck strain
one of the key issues from making this
display truly great is that they have
not gone all the way when it comes to
ports we have one hdmi 1.4 two hdmi 2.1
ports and two hdmi 2.0 ports
if only rog had made all the hdmi ports
2.1 it would have future proved this
display easy an issue with the pods
placement is that there's a clear lack
of space with all the wires to trail out
with the hdmi 2.1 ports pointed
downwards it will compete with the panel
placement and it can get messy with the
ports mostly located on the right of the
display as you are facing it do be
mindful on how your desk is set up
in addition the display has a generous
amount of usb 3.2 gen 1 type a ports as
well these can be found at the top and
at the side of the display the ports on
the top are a bit questionable
but you might find a home for it for
devices with wireless dongles when it
comes to pc gaming this is where the
monitor truly shines
with two hdmi 2.1 ports for your ps5 and
xbox series x console fans are not left
out
being one of the few oled displays in
the market that support g-sync you're
assured that you'll be able to get the
best out of this 3840 by 2164k display
to enjoy hdr10 in its full glory
featuring a max refresh rate of 138hz
this feature is not enabled out of the
box by default so you need to navigate
to the menus to turn it on manually
in addition the display also offers a
few options as well if you like to go
from a 4k display to an ultra right in
the form of a 34 inch 21x9 aspect ratio
there are additional options for 24 inch
and 27 inch as well
these modes all enjoy the same high
refresh rate and 0.1 ms response time
if pc gaming is a priority the rog pg48
uq is by far one of the best picks
however when it comes to the console
experience the colors do come across as
more muted as we like
i imagine that a filmmaker update is
necessary to get the most out of the
display
for any user investing into oleds
it might come down to a tossup between
getting an lg tv or the rog
the display comes with a fairly simple
remote that opens up a rudimentary ui
which we see with pretty much all rog
displays out there
when the oled alternatives come with a
proper interface
rog might need to step up more to show
greater value in the product's overall
experience outside of just hardware at
the moment the display has the monopoly
of being one of the few rare oled
displays that come supplied with display
port 1.4
and are needed for pc users to make full
use of in addition from time to time
there's a pop-up that appears to remind
users to run a pixel refresh
having followed the prompt it still pops
up time and again which might be rather
irritating for some
most self-respecting pc gamers will
likely opt for a solid headset to use at
the desk but the pg48u cube has included
speakers if you like to give your ears a
rest sound wise the audio comes off as
relatively hollow and it's not one of
the stronger points of the display
despite the featuring harman kardon
branding
i don't like this part of my car back
when they were still building midgar
there was an accident
from a hardware standpoint the rog
pg48uq is a solid contender if you are
looking for a oled display alternatives
outside of lg
especially for pc use there are a few
questionable moves with the lack of
complete hdmi 2.1 support which i would
wager then it ultimately will come down
to the price for this display in your
market between this or a proper oled tv
however the inclusion of a displayport
is by far one of the most compelling
reasons for the pc master race folks to
sit up and take notice that's it thanks
for watching this video if you thought
oled was good check out my current
favorite tv of 2022 right now it's
surprising that this tv from samsung hit
all the right notes a small warning
though the moment this tv power's on you
might get sucked in and wonder yourself
hours later wondering where all that
time went after staring at this beauty
of a display